it appears that Marvel and DC fans have
slightly different preferences when it
comes to how they get their respective
fixes a new survey conducted by
streaming and cord-cutting news site
flicks examining the attitudes of
Americans towards streaming versus movie
theater viewing revealed that Marvel
Cinematic Universe aficionados are more
likely than DC diehards to catch the
latest installment in the theater the
difference was relatively slight but
with millions upon millions of dollars
at play each time a superhero tentpole
picture hits screens it still feels
pretty significant you're not the only
one cursed with knowledge I only curse
is you survey respondents were asked if
they would consider catching the next
installment of four popular franchises
at home rather than in the theater with
those uninterested in any given
franchise being excluded from the
results when it came to mighty Marvel
versus the distinguished competition 34
percent insisted they would rather see
the next MCU flick in the theatres as
compared to 27 percent for the DC movie
universe again those 7 percentage points
make a pretty big difference when you're
talking about millions of moviegoers and
those numbers are suggestive of a couple
of different things first it's pretty
obvious that Marvel Studios has utterly
captured the hearts of fans considering
that a plurality of moviegoers of all
ages would be willing to pay a premium
to watch first-run films in the comfort
of their homes the fact that the next
MCU movie whatever it might be would
entice fully a third of those people who
want to see it to head out to the
theater even if they have the option of
watch at home is pretty impressive
second the DC Cinematic Universe may
have suffered a bit from the
comparatively poor quality of its early
offerings but that doesn't mean that
fans still aren't on board with what
Warner Brothers and DC films are cooking
up next with over a quarter of them
preferring the theater experience over
watching at home for the next
installment it's clear that there's
still a great deal of goodwill toward
the franchise recent hits such as
Aquaman Shazam and Joker have probably
helped quite a bit in this regard as for
the other two franchises 34 percent of
interested movie
the same number scored by the MCU
asserted that the next entry in the
disney-owned Star Wars franchise would
be a must-watch in the theatres the
final franchise in question warner
brothers owned harry potter which could
draw 25% of its fans back to the theater
with another installment these were just
a few of the interesting tidbits of
information yielded by the study which
took a broad view of the opinions of a
wide cross-section of Americans
regarding the convenience of streaming
versus the experience of theater viewing
respondents were lumped into the
categories of millennial Jenna and baby
boomer and if you think you've got each
age range pegged you're likely to be
shocked at some of the results for
example when it came to the simple
question of whether respondents would
prefer to see new movies in general at
home or in theaters you might think
Millennials would be all about streaming
as compared to the other age groups but
if you did think that you would
apparently be wrong by far
Gen X respondents came down most heavily
on the side of home viewing with a
whopping 73 percent saying they would
prefer to stream new releases as for the
responses of Millennials and boomers to
the question they were not that
different 61% of the former preferred
home viewing as compared to 63% of the
latter and factoring in neutral
responses the percentage of respondents
from each age group that straight up
preferred theater viewing was the same
31% regardless of age group the surveys
response has indicated that the
forthcoming so-called streaming wars are
no joke fully two-thirds of respondents
also asserted that as streaming services
proliferate an earnest over the next
three years they will definitely see
fewer movies and theaters
even though slightly over half of those
responding agreed that movies produced
for in theater viewing as opposed to
streaming originals were generally more
entertaining as to the franchise
specific question though one could argue
that Disney and Warner Brothers should
take very different things away from the
responses Disney would be well-served to
keep doing what it's been doing
particularly as that pertains to be MCU
Warner Brothers on the other hand could
stand to double down on its
recalibration efforts of the last couple
years one final note it should be very
interesting to see with Marvel Studios
planning to extend
MC use tendrils to the small screen via
toon to debut stream or Disney Plus
whether fans will be just as psyched to
catch the next chapter in theaters and
say two or three years Marvel has
consistently gotten butts in theater
seats for over a decade and the studio
scored the highest grossing film of all
time just this year with Avengers
endgame but the times are a-changing I
see this is an absolute win check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite comic book movies are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]